♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est un retour définitif en
Colombie pour Ingrid Betancourt.
Ses enfants, qui vivent
en France, sont adultes
INGRID BETANCOURT
- Je crois que la seule
véritable force qui explique
un retour après tout ce que nous
la Colombie, qui est essentiel
dans mon cas. Et je mpmprends
très bien que mes enfants ne
partagent pas ça. Mais pour moi,
bonheur à être ici.
- Six ans et demi de captivité
enduré les pires souffrances
en compaieie de centaines
d'autres otages de la guérilla.
Un martyr qu'elle raconte deeeee
"Même le silence a une fin".
croyait sur le point de mourir
ont suscité  s sympathie et
l'indignation du monde entier,
se traduisant par des
et en particulier en France,
oùe e gouvernement a tout fait
pour obtenir sa libération.
- Il n'y a pas de problèmevavav!
Elle est vivante.
- C'est une opérioion
spectaculaire de l'armée
colombienne qui l'a finalement
trois otages américains.
- Je suis lolombienne,
mais je suis Française.
Mon coeur est partagé.
Bogota par le président Alvaro
Ure,e, tout comme à Paris,
où le président Sarkozy lui
décerne la légion d'honneur.
très important pour moi de me
reconstruiresysychologiquement,
de sortir de cette...
de ce qu'a été le contrecoup
reconstruire ma famille.
Et ç ç ça a été ma priorité.
- Quatorze ans plus tard,
psychologiquement,
INGRID BETANCOURT, politicienne
- Lecicicatrices sont là.
C'est une période de ma vie
que je vais jamais oublier,
Mais j'ai réussi véritablementàs
ces années, c'est-à-dire
me dire : Bon, j'ai quand mê c r
l'être humain, sur ma capacité
de résistance, sur... voilà,
les priorités de la vie,
la possibilité de voe e e e e e.
Je n'aurais évidemment pas voulu
vrvre ce que j'ai vécu, mais
je pense que dans la vie,
il faut construire à partir
- La Colombie a signé la paix
avec les FARC en 2016.
Elle a appuyé tout le processus
et confronté ses ravisseurieieié
un moment extraordinaire.
Et moi, j'ai été à fond avec
le processus de paix. Je pense
que ça a été la metitititititit.
Évidemment, il y a des choses
qui doivent être faites,
par exemple la réparation
des
le fait que les victimes
connaissent la vérité
de beaucoup de choses.
Il y a une vérité juridique,
mais ce n'est pas suffisant.
Moi, comme victime,
j'ai acc
que mes ravisseurs n'aillent pas
en prison contre le fait
d'aller en justice, donner toute
la vérité, accepter les crimes
se démobiliser...
C'est quand même énorme!
♪ ♪ ♪
- La Colombie ne va pas bien,
elle le sa..
- Aujourd'hui, nous avons
22 millions de Colombiens
économique très précaire,
do 7 7 millions qui sont
au bord de la famine.
C'est très, très grave pouresesn
de changer le système et c'est :
il faut arrêter la corruption,
il faut qu'on arrête.
Il le faut véritablement.
Nous n'avons ps s de solution.
- Le fléau numéro un,
c'
- Je l'ai dit depuis 30 ans :pa.
Il y a 30 ans, nous avions déjà
des poussées de corruption
fortes parce que c'était
le processus "8000". Odededededr
avec le financement par
le cartel de Cali. Ça a ouvert
une porte où, finalement, comme
il y a eu une  y y y y y y y y e
sensation qu'en fait, on pouvait
tout faire et ils ont tout fait.
Les paramilitaires sont rentrés,
les tr
rentrés. Enfin, tout a été...
toutes les instances de
corruption, là où il y a
beaucoup, beaucoup d'argent
la politique.
♪ ♪
- Le carburant de cette
corruption c'est le narcotrafic.
de la cocaïne du monde.
Il y a quatranans, c'était 50 %.
- Bon, de toute façon,
tout s'imbrique et tout passe
par le problème de la drogue;
que ce soit la corruption,
de sécurité, la violence,
l'environnemen....
L'Amazonie est en feu,
le déboisement, mais accéléré,
et ça, c'est vraiment le trafic
de la drogue. Donc partout, les
aussi pour la Colombie,
c'est énorme!
- Ingrid Betancourt est en tinin
de relancer le Parti Vert
oxygène, qu'elle avait fondé
par la guérilla.
Elle a l'intention dlele placer
en opposition farouche
au nouveau président de gauche
- Su presidente!
- Est-ce quie vous êtes
optimiste pour l'avenir
de la Colombie malgré
tout ce qui se passe?
qu'on va s'en sortir